1977 is the first time we did an mri
okay so that's not a long time ago it's
july 3rd 1977. so
up until 1977 we don't fully know
what the brain is doing right up until
1977. so a lot of it if somebody's
exercise doing you know
exorcisms it's just maybe a guessing
game because we don't know
1977 we come out with a magnetic you
know resonance imaging so i just did an
mri last week i just went through an mri
two weeks ago for my hand broken two
ligaments
fractured my six-year-old daughter broke
my thumb
something she's gonna brag about for the
rest of her life i've broken a couple
bones in my life one of them was broken
by a six-year-old she's so proud of it
she laughs every time i say so you go
get an mri done in the brain
and then you see the two sides of it
right you got the structural mri
you got the
definitional mri okay one of them is
more the structure the other one's the
activity when they did the mri when they
looked at some folks that had you know
they they thought they were being
possessed
uh on one end you have the two sides of
the brain okay the
hippocampus and the amiga amigdale
amygdala right
one of the sides it was a reduction of
19.2 percent and the other one was a
31.6 reduction in the region of the
brain that gets extremely creative and
emotional right
and then
the argument that this doctor was making
the fact that now that we have the mri
we are realizing
that the brain can really do a number on
you when it goes on its own specifically
the side that's the amygdala side that's
more the creative the activity you can
kind of see what's going on with it so
the this is what i mean by education
technology advancement a lot of this is
taking the credibility out to say all
these years we thought there was really
people being possessed but we're at a
point right now that when somebody's
going through that rather than going and
seeing an exorcist maybe they got to go
get an mri done of their brain
to see what the activity they're
noticing then the doctor can say yeah
this person's going through this here's
what their challenge they're having what
are your thoughts when you hear a doctor
making an argument to say
the mri now validates that you know
there's no such thing as being possessed
and needing a an exorcist what would you
say to that
i go back again from a faith perspective
in the new testament when jesus sent his
disciples out
he gave them authority over unclean
spirits but he also gave them power to
cure those who were sick so jesus
himself made a distinction between
ailments that were due to demonic causes
and ones that were just purely physical
in nature
and i think that that continues today so
yeah there are some that are certainly
due to uh physical maladies but i still
believe that there are some that are due
to demonic causes but again that would
be going and doing
that investigation trying to determine
how that came about so when you said
before they come to see you they got to
go see the doctor they got to have this
they got to have that is a part of it
nmri is a part of it to go see
the brain activity that's taking place
or no whatever the
expert would recommend
yeah like and by the way when you guys
go through the exorcism do you do you
ever communicate directly with a doctor
of the patient or the individual or have
you ever had a
direct communication with a doctor or no
i i will say that always
but not all these other professionals
would be willing to accept that maybe
they're spiritual causes
so they may not be willing to speak with
me or they may not be willing to speak
with you right got it so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]